I'm just smoking blunts with gunit on
stage and at the time it was like a
hardcore felony to smoke in Nevada they
had the most no tolerance everybody on
stage just blazing blazing bro once we
started it was like everybody in the
crowd the whole Arena started you look
up it was just like a cloud of smoke and
not every celebrity would come out and
smoke like I brought LeBron out in Ohio
and it wasn't like he smoking he dig so
in Vegas the whole time I was thinking
man they lock my ass up for this you
know what I'm saying but it went by
smooth we made history you know I'm one
to can say I've been on the stage in
front of thousands of people with steo
smoking a damn blunt where we wasn't
supposed to smoke at you dig yeah